[Music]
hey
everybody hey mango says how the [ __ ]
can there be a dislike the show hasn't
even started i saw
that i was like what kind of troll got
in here
[ __ ] are haters man they're [ __ ]
haters well it might be like spam
because i've noticed like in the past
couple months i've gotten like a lot of
spam stuff it's usually like um
something like www.hotgirls.com like
my sister they're disliking your show
they just like your [ __ ]
now there's always two dislikes usually
unless it's a real popular show like our
ed and the rain warren where you got
like [ __ ] 500 thumbs up and [ __ ]
300 though
those are legitimate people that don't
like your opinion yeah yeah they're
religious people
because i've gotten that's that is
easily easily the one i've gotten like
the most hate mail
yeah i'm like the most lorraine ward i'm
just saying man they weren't legit
i don't think they were gonna have to do
well they were on some legit cases
but they were i don't think they were
they weren't legit yeah they were just
kind of like walton
and well as soon as soon as ed said that
he fought and killed a werewolf
i mean hey that's a good segue for today
it is
look at that see you got talent for this
jen show the show your new birthday
shirt yeah i showed it yesterday
yeah it's got boobs in it now it's got
boobs in it now
hey yeah sexual assault
yeah it is crazy it's crazy already yeah
um yeah so we decided like i said
uh in case you hadn't uh you know got
the memo
that we're actually gonna start doing
for the matinee we're gonna expand it
back to like
2010 or so because i get sick of trying
to find stuff from 2020 all the time
so we actually decided to do a 2015
movie called
howl which is on shutter and i think
it's also on to be
so you can watch it for free or you can
watch it on shutter either way it's up
to you
this is actually a british uh werewolf
movie
and it was directed by paul
hyatt who is the same guy i'm not sure
if this is his first directorial
job but he's the same guy that did the
effects for
the descent and dog soldiers
and the woman in black and attacked the
block
so this guy is like a kind of like
well-regarded effects guy and so he
decided that he was going to do his own
werewolf movie
um and it's actually pretty good yeah
that was
all the werewolves are glad dancing they
are well the first werewolves
shows up and looks like [ __ ] the hair
and everything [ __ ]
glenn dancing on bad roads yeah
i like the werewolves in this one
because they don't look like i mean
the werewolves and dog soldier dog
soldiers are probably my favorite
werewolves just because they look
and the ones in the howling are good too
but these ones they went a little more
in a man-like
direction but that's cool because they
don't want him to like look the same as
all the other ones and he probably
didn't want to
because he had worked on dog soldier
he's probably like well i don't want
them to look like dog soldiers because
it'll just look like i'm doing that
again their back legs had the dog legs
on it they looked good well yeah you
kind of have to do that but the upper
bodies kind of look kind of man like
it looked like a caveman kind of it's a
good like attivistic
sort of good it was like a big old mouth
with like all but
story was good um look man the budget on
this thing was like only a million
pounds
all right that's nothing yeah and like i
said before i said the british
are real good at dealing with a limited
budget
for a lot of different reasons all right
uh i think probably the
biggest reason is that
england has real acting schools they got
real actors
there you know they take the theater
very seriously you know
not so much hollywood the best hollywood
actors really a lot of times are british
pretending to be
americans so they actually care about
their craft
you know in their trade uh so you have a
tendency to have
good acting in a british movie even if
it's cheap
not an american movie a low-budget
american movie you know what i mean
you're
you're basically casted depending on how
well you did on the couch
or how much money you contributed or how
much cocaine that you contributed
that's what got you in the movie all
right it's [ __ ] you know what i mean
american movies are kind of like
organized crime really
not so much britain so well oracle even
said
oracle mentioned that they said they
respect the writer more than hollywood
does yeah
that is the impression and they try to
make a good product
you know even even getting down to like
the score
and the music you know you know so and
the score and this one was good
i judge a movie by its score well i feel
like it's got a good score they give a
[ __ ]
it well it's something that a lot of
people don't really think about when you
watch a movie but unless there's like a
really shitty one and then you notice it
yeah you know what i mean right but i do
feel like it's kind of an
underappreciated especially in horror
movies because so much has to do with
like the sound design and stuff
so i do feel like a lot of people kind
of neglect your average low-budget
american flick
the score you don't even notice the
score because it's just some generic
[ __ ] accents that they put in there
every now and then maybe they put a song
in it
you know but you don't really notice it
that much and that's a sign of a [ __ ]
cheap movie
and in a good movie the score kind of
is apparent you know what i mean even
though you maybe not noticing it
it's just well it's making you feel
making you feel a certain way
that you're supposed to be right right
exactly you know without you really like
being able to emotive
yeah you know so i constantly just watch
it i'm watching for it
so the acting was good filmography the
way it was shot was good
story was okay i'm gonna say like my
only critique
like the characters some of them weren't
as fleshed out as
they could in terms of like like this
movie right it reminded me of train to
busan
yeah because it's on a train and there's
like a group of characters like a core
group of characters
but we're trying to boost them like i
actually felt deeply like i cared about
the characters
a lot just how they express themselves
and stuff like this movie
i'd say except for the one dude that me
and jenny both hated and
i just keep looking at the budget for a
million pounds this is [ __ ]
citizen kane well yeah
i guess so yeah yeah i mean like i said
i my only critique is yes it does take a
little
bit of a long time to get for for the
werewolves to make an appearance
that's the only critique i'm going to
give this payoff though there is yeah i
do like that it yeah it takes a while to
get there but like because i think it's
only 89 minutes long but once it starts
there's like all kind of really good
gore and like really good werewolves and
there's like a lot of werewolves and
there's also a thing where
because i feel like this is kind of hit
or miss in a lot of werewolf movies if
you get bit by a werewolf then you turn
it
over so it's like a zombie kind of thing
so i'm not really sure a lot of werewolf
movies do that
you know what i mean i mean i guess um
an american werewolf in london
he got bit by a werewolf but then it
like took until the next month for him
to turn into a werewolf he didn't like
immediately turn into a werewolf
so i guess there's some wiggle room on
that but yeah this it's weird because
now didn't train to busan came out in
what 2016 2017 something like that
so it's like were these being made at
the same time
or was did train to busan get an idea
from this one or because this
did not get a theatrical release it
basically did a couple of like film
festivals around the world and then it
just
went straight to video and straight to
vod so
i don't know if it was just a case of
you know maybe the people who made train
to busan
like saw this or like oh hey that's a
good idea except let's do it with like
fast moving zombies instead of like a
pack of werewolves
because it seemed like there were a lot
of like you know the
the [ __ ] knuckle character that we both
hated that we were just like die
but you know what i mean um that guy had
an analog
in train to busan like that businessman
that was oh yeah
that businessman that was just kind of
like me me me it's just like i'm just
going to push old people and children
off the train just so the team
don't eat me that kind of guy but you
know culturally that guy was very
significant for
korean culture yeah because you know
having lived in korea you know i'll tell
you
korea is an authority it's an
authoritarian culture
and the average korean person is
you know how do i say it politely i
don't want to call them cucks or
anything they're just kind of hey they
just did i just did call them
they're they're they're very responsive
to authority
and that particular character and trying
to boost on khan
was demonstrating to korean people that
authority doesn't always have your
[ __ ] best in in intentions in mind
that uh you know what i mean they're
very corporate and very hierarchy
you know everything everything's very
much a hierarchy and
uh which is you know it's a very eastern
way of doing things
uh they tend to kind of be trusting of
authority and in that particular movie
like no no no no
the authority in that case only cared
about themselves
which i liked that i thought that was a
great message this dude in this movie
wasn't really an authority he was just a
passenger i think
yeah right yeah he was just he was just
a passenger on the train yeah and he
kind of like tried to like drop his nuts
and take over and he was just like
an irredeemable douchebag yeah in the
cur in the korean version he's using
he's using normal korean culture
to establish his authority and trying to
give out orders and get
all the organization and getting
everybody in lockstep not to save them
to save his own ass yeah
which that was [ __ ] beautiful with
the way they wrote that character
yeah so that's one thing i do think that
like the character development was
better and trying to boost on but
yeah you know um this one it's like i
liked
you know the characters except for that
guy um but i honestly i didn't remember
a lot of their names and they didn't do
like a lot of
i remembered the old pers the old lady's
name was jenny because it's the same as
my name
um you know what i mean so i remember
that and i remember like her husband
saying her name a bunch of times
but other than that i didn't really
remember because it was just kind of
like you know the douchebag the fat guy
the blonde girl you know what i mean
like the young girl with the phone like
the noisy chick or whatever
so i so i'm not really sure if they did
it on purpose because they were just
kind of like
i don't know it was just kind of like
here's a bunch of strangers
because that's pretty much the indian
guy he's like oh and the indian guy yeah
so that's kind of like the the whole
premise of the movie
is basically they're on this train it's
a red
and um they hit a deer
and then they're out in a dead zone so
you know nobody's because it's real
remote and i guess no so nobody's cell
phones work and they can't like the
radio isn't working
so they hit a deer and the fuel line
breaks
so they're stuck out there in the middle
of the night and then
the conductor of the train played by
sean pertwee who was
also in dog soldiers which was another
british werewolf movie he doesn't last
long in this one though spoiler alert
um so he's the conductor he goes off the
train and disappears they don't know
where he's at
and so the rest of the workers on the
train and the passengers have to and
there's not that many of them so they
have to kind of like pull together
and figure out how they're going to get
the train going again and like then they
find out that there's werewolves
and the werewolves seem to be able to
like tear through the side of the
train i mean because don't they get that
fat guy like out
they tear off like the top of the
[ __ ] roof of the thing and like pull
them out the bathroom or whatever or
they climbed into the bathroom
i think so yeah i think they did the
only thing the only thing that kind of
disturbed me about the train aspect of
the movie is the train stopped it sat on
tracks for a long time
you would think there'd be another train
behind it well i was just like i know
the whole middle of nowhere thing but i
was like dude they did they call
emergency services like
yeah i don't live in england but i
remember being kind of small and tight
like how fast can a freaking ambulance
or a plane or something like
you know there's a lady bleeding out and
i think they did call for help they
talked to someone didn't they
they did well what ended up happening
was they were trying to call somebody on
the radio and then it was all staticky
and i guess they couldn't get a message
across
the chick's phone worked folks and then
yeah nobody's phone worked but then
the girls phone was the only one that
worked like she got some bars but then
she got killed and i guess like the the
phone got destroyed or lost or whatever
like because they found her ass later
but yeah so
i mean as i said it was kind of like a
long build up and you know the the
characters are not
super super well developed um they do
try to do
you know like the blonde lady and the
teenage girl like kind of have a little
conversation and
i liked the scene with the old guy
talking about um
back in the 60s like you know this train
like went
like derailed like out in the same area
and like they when the people got there
to rescue them they're like everyone was
dead and they never figured out what's
going on so i liked that kind of
campfire story kind of aspect so they
were like calling back to some other
[ __ ]
there was that little romance going on
too with the people people that worked
on the train
yeah yeah yeah like the guy that was he
was like the kind of the main
protagonist
and i liked his because he had kind of a
character arc where
at the beginning he was trying to get a
supervisor position
but he didn't get it and then he found
out this other douche that worked there
like got it and was like rubbing it in
his face
and then he was like asking out this
girl that like you know sold the chicken
sandwiches on the train and she was like
trying to let him down and stuff so he
was
so that whole arc of the thing was like
him trying to like man up and like fight
the werewolves off and uh
i'm not gonna like spoil the end but i
did like the end was very satisfying i
thought
you know what i mean yeah i mean i i
like what can be
i like what happened to that to that one
dude that i hated
i was like i was like all right yeah
because i was like but you better not
let that [ __ ] get away
but yeah it's like i honestly i thought
this was like
not the best it's not as good as dog
soldiers i mean dog soldiers like i said
that's easily one of my favorite
werewolf movies
but um it was pretty damn good i thought
it was pretty like entertaining
yeah i didn't i didn't see anything you
know wrong with it
i mean it was like i said not quite as
good as dog soldiers or the howling or
something
but um in there it was in there
you know what i mean yes it's a
different kind of werewolf visually
but i like that they did something
different yeah i thought that was
acceptable i think
they looked really cool in a dark it
looked like a scary giant mouth
caveman with dog legs kind of yeah you
know what i mean yeah then they were
kind of furry with
glowing eyes and ears and stuff and i
did i especially like the scenes of them
in the dark like when they got off the
train a couple times and were like
trying to like find the conductor and
[ __ ] and then like you saw like these
little shadows with like the glowing
eyes and [ __ ] that was cool
yeah it looked demonic yeah yeah
like a wolf demon man yeah did they
really go into like
why they're there or where they came
from well i guess because that old guy
had said the thing about the trendy
railing in 1963 i think he said so i
guess the werewolves had just always
been there
yeah i wonder what they were just eating
deer until yeah i guess so
they went for people because i guess the
deer that the train hit at the beginning
was maybe running away from them
and then like the trains you took our
dinner we're taking you yeah and it's
like oh hey there's little meat sticks
in there
let's get those you know what i mean so
maybe that's what it was
i mean that's the first thing i thought
mango says howl is on the horror channel
in the uk tonight oh okay
yeah like i said over here it's on
shutter and it's on to be as well yeah
fourth george
said i used to commute by train in the
early 90s i would have been overjoyed to
find a werewolf on board
i know that feeling somebody asked if we
finished pale rider yeah we finished
pale rider
did you think of that writer oh it's
great yeah yeah it's it's different than
high plains drifter like in a way
but it's he compares yeah so similar
yeah
high plains drifter does better because
it it he [ __ ] people over for a lot
longer throughout that whole [ __ ]
there's way less action but the
characters are very good
so the side note yeah yeah i liked both
of those but yeah
i mean high plains drifter is like
probably easily my favorite yeah he kind
of had that demonic element yeah
because i just like that kind of
supernatural yeah i like that
yeah somebody said i like the werewolves
from underworld i don't even remember
what this i just counted i was like yeah
underworld the version of vampires and
the version of the werewolves are like
perfect i remember liking the first one
but i don't think i liked any of the
other sequels
i don't know if you watched the third
one that was the i don't think historic
like
back in time one rise of the likens so
there's a lot more werewolves in that
one
i might have seen that because for a
long time remember that channel that um
that uh [ __ ] robert rodriguez does like
lrank
yeah and that what they would do for a
long time like every weekend they would
have like an
all-day like movie marathon it's like
we're going to show you know all the
phantasm movies we're going to show all
the godzilla movies we're going to
all you know but i think they showed
like all the underworld ones so i think
i was kind of like in and out like
there's only three right no i think
there's like five now but i hate it i
think i hated four and five like just
stop after three and you're good
okay which is usually the case with most
movies after three
yeah i think once you get to three three
is usually like mal okay
but i don't really need any more of that
please stop and then they don't stop
what i remember of them is they had a
cute girl starring in them and
everything was really blue
the whole [ __ ] vampires are like
they're like industrial as well yeah
yeah
great i love this vampires are sexy
they're castle
like the whole night like their sexy
vampires yeah yeah
get you a vinyl suit and run around with
your little guns shoot some silver bolts
and some ultraviolet bullets
okay
yeah all right glowing turtle wants to
know if there's any western werewolf
movies
i wish if that is there's gonna be i
mean
i can't think of one they're probably
really shitty but yeah there's probably
i'm sure like sci-fi or asylum or
something some mexican ones
that's [ __ ] kind of odd i bet your
name
because yeah cause i've seen like zombie
westerns
i think i've seen like vampire western i
don't know if i've seen any werewolf but
there's not a lot of werewolf movies
mexicans would like make
a [ __ ] western luchador mag uh movie
i would watch that or like a yeah well
there it is like on
on mystery science theater they did a
western vampire they did a luchadore
and yeah uh vampire women samson versus
the vampire one
yeah samson the silver mask man yeah i
would imagine back in the 60s or 70s
they probably
was terrible yeah they probably had
smashed it from mexico
i mean it made a good mst episode but i
don't think i could sit through it
without that because it
would have been boring it was really
really boring yeah it's like a lot of
the movies that they do
are that's you can't watch them without
their [ __ ] jokes all right so uh
that'll do it for
today's live stream uh we'll see you
guys again not until saturday i'm going
to take a break yeah
this is my last show this is sophie's
last livestream
i'm sure sophie will be back yeah she'll
come back and visit us maybe next year
that would be good yeah
if the world doesn't go to [ __ ] i'll be
back yeah
yeah can't we say much to [ __ ] we'll see
keep it going guys all right so we will
see you guys
on saturday thanks for dropping by bye